5 artistes ont refusé de rejoindre le
jury de The Voice alors depuis 2012 TF1
diffuse le télé-crochet The Voice en ce
moment la chaîne diffuse la saison 12
depuis le 25 février et beaucoup
d'artistes sont succédé pour rejoindre
le jury et pourtant Christophe Maé par
exemple Hélène Segara Patrick Bruel
Laurent Voulzy ou encore Charline Spirit
c'est qui
ont refusé de rejoindre le jury il y en
a beaucoup d'autres en fait alors
regardez on en parle juste après
à première vue on pourrait croire que
pour un artiste rejoindre le jury de The
Voice le célèbre télécroché de TF1 et
d'une consécration
et bien pas pour tout le monde a priori
depuis sa mise à l'antenne en 2012 en
France l'émission qui a vu défiler 17
coachs a également essuyé plusieurs
refus cinq au total
malgré les énormes cachés promus au
chanteur par la production et TF1
Christophe Maé a refusé d’intégrer le
jury en 2014 j'ai juste envie de te dire
un grand bravo quoi mais selon les
dernières rumeurs il pourrait néanmoins
changer d'avis pour la saison prochaine
la production aurait aimé mettre la main
sur une autre star de la chanson
française en la personne de Patrick
Bruel mais aussi bien en 2012 que ces
derniers temps pour remplacer Florent
Pagny le refus de l'artiste a été
catégorie car une règle du show ne lui
convient pas du tout c'est pas tant que
le candidat choisisse l'artiste mais que
l'artiste saute de joie comme si il
avait eu un Oscar Hollywood parce que un
candidat choisi je trouve ça très
bizarre Hélène Segara et Laurent Voulzy
ont également été approchés au lancement
de l'émission mais pour des raisons de
timing cela n'a pas pu se faire
la production a également essayé de
mettre la main sur une star
internationale Charlie du speakery la
chanteuse du groupe Texas qui n'a pas
été tendre en refusant finalement de
participer à l'aventure je n'étais pas
prête à faire des compromis avec ce que
je suis je refuse de dire un candidat oh
mon Dieu tu es fantastique j'aurais aimé
chanter aussi bien que toi qu'est-ce
qu'il pense qu'ils vont trouver Michael
Jackson bref selon vous est-ce un
accélérateur de carrière pour un artiste
d'être Co dans The Voice
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et toi c'était Charlie qui est quand
même génial c'est quand même un peu
violent ce qu'elle a dit je trouve
ces crétins
ni la version française ni les autres
versions parce que il passe leur temps à
dire non à des gens aussi et leur disent
pas mon dieu mais comme j'aimerais bien
chanter aussi bien que toi c'est pas
vrai d'ailleurs ils savent souvent que
les candidats chantent mieux que ils le
disent ils l'avoue il parle de leur
sensibilité c'est parfaitement idiot et
gratuit de dire un truc comme ça voilà
la sortie ça va je serai du samedi on
est tranquille
c'est à dire qu'il y a personne qui
vient pour défoncer les candidats le mot
d'ordre de TF1 c'est quand même toujours
de dire non pas pour le moment mais tu
as fait pas la mentir
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien une fois
avoir quelqu'un qui vraiment soit cash
et voilà il dit vraiment
je pense en fait j'avais discuté avec un
une ancienne je veux pas dire son nom
mais c'est une ancienne personne de la
Star Ac de l'année dernière qui hésitait
encore à y retourner ou pas et qui me
disait en fait le souci quand tu es dans
des émissions comme ça sur des barnums
comme ça sur TF1 c'est qu'après tu
accapares par TF1 et tu ne peux rien
faire d'autre produit TF1 période
émissions de Noël de Pâques de la
promotion et je pense que quand tu es
artiste un peu envie d'être indépendant
et ça te saoule un peu de faire passer
il y a une grosse différence un Bruel
qui est certainement est dans ce cas de
figure et franchement Hélène Segara
j'adore Hélène si tu nous regardes mais
qui est pas non plus au top de sa
carrière et qui pourrait
et après elle a demandé enfin les
laisser entendre que peut-être et puis
finalement ils ont pas à rappeler
déjà dans la recherche allez Jack dans
Incroyable Talent enfin on va pas
l'avoir avec mercredi à Baba Rome
trouver la maman voilà les paroles de ma
mère tous les jours à la fin sont très
la fin le petit lapin non mais après ils
sont très critiqués aussi les coachs
parce qu'ils sont extrêmement bien payés
et ils travaillent peu ils font leur
séquences filmées pour coacher leur
artiste du boulot quand même c'est du
boulot
la carrière dépend de ton avis aussi
c'est très grave moi je trouve que c'est
une responsabilité quand même que les
artistes ont que certains ne veulent pas
avoir c'est ça c'est difficile de juger
toujours quelqu'un
Isa il y a plus souvent le cas inverse
hein moi je connais des gens qui ont été
jurés de la nouvelle de The Voice comme
Julien Clerc qui aurait bien remplie
pour une saison suivante et c'est TF1
qui a dit non donc il y a tous les cas
de figure et c'est pas vrai ils sont des
fois très ferme en disant non et sans
dire revient plus tard reviens plus tard
non non non non ils sont bienveillants
mais ils sont fermés mais ferme ça veut
pas dire brutal ah Jean-Michel bercer le
cerveau peut-être qu'il va sortir
quelque chose non non
je suis gêné de dire ça parce que je les
adore biflé au lit Vianney
mais je trouve ça prend on voit pas une
très bonne image pour le pour l'artiste
je trouve que c'est
faut pas avoir un agenda surbooké pour
accepter de participer à une émission
qui dure trois mois etc des périodes de
flottement un artiste c'est pas
compliqué il sort un album il sort un
premier single après il sort un album et
après il y a la tournée de cet album et
après tu as plus rien pendant quelques
temps et puis tu as besoin de te
reconstruire tu as besoin de voir autre
chose d'entendre d'autres choses et donc
c'est pas normal tous ces gens-là ont
été un grand Jour de Foot après tu
restes Grand Jour de Foot des narbitre
des autres machins
je peux comprendre en fait le refus
parce que quand tu as été un bon
chanteur est-ce que tu peux être un bon
coach c'est ça
un gros challenge parce que tu peux
[__] ta carrière en l'air aussi si tu
si tu as raison justement
quel est votre préférée qui trouvez-vous
autant en tout cas le meilleur
c'est une émission bienveillante mais le
meilleur Vianney moi j'adore
Bigflo et Oli
et plutôt tendre et souvent émouvant
mais quand ils ont dit non
mais ils ont dit non souvent Amel Amel
aussi elle a fait péter le programme en
apportant vraiment un truc du jeune et
puis elle met la patate quand elle est
là Amel est très émouvante dans la
chambre à chaque fois investi au bord
des larmes et ça j'aime moi quand je
vois ça à la télé ça me touche j'adore
un mail et après Sophie
elle est vraiment elle a une sensibilité
elle est d'ailleurs enfin pour moi c'est
elle qui a la voix la plus incroyable
même si voilà c'est dans des styles
différents on va dire mais c'est elle la
plus grande chanteuse de des jurés et
même si on adore Bigflo et Oli ou
Vianney moi je trouve que ça manque un
peu de pointure quoi Zazie c'est une
pointure ça c'est clair mais moi je
préférais à l'époque
pour tout le monde d'accord super
on est loin de Florent Pagny on est loin
de Mika qu'ils sont des stars quand même
enfin
Bigflo et Oli je trouve super
d'accord moi je suis pas d'accord parce
que on a écouté un concert il a une voix
absolument surprenante
c'est une vraie voix
vous vous trompez parce que c'est un
patron de la chanson française
[Applaudissements]
celui qui manque vraiment pour moi c'est
panique
mais c'est vrai qu'ils auraient pu
reprendre je trouve des grosses stars
quoi des trucs
en pleine forme pour son bouquin en
pleine forme très heureux tout va bien
ici son traitement et il sera en concert
Florent pagnet panier à partir du mois
de juillet
en revenir aux gros stars qui pourraient
refuser les de plus en plus ces
émissions comme ça je sais pas si vous
avez remarqué mais je trouve que de plus
en plus les vrais points sur les grosses
tas ce pince un peu le nez quand elles
vont sur les bateaux télé on a de moins
en moins de stars qui viennent faire la
promo le jeu il joue plus le jeu ça les
intéresse pas n'oublions pas que sont
les émissions dans son sens qui font
quand même qu'ils aient cette 6 millions
il y a encore quelques années qui font 5
qui font quatre qui font 3 qui terminent
à deux et demi
c'est pas exactement la même quand tu
fais 8 millions de samedi soir et quand
tu fais 2 millions et demi
bien sûr tout le temps mais oui mais
après Francesca par
donne-moi mes
différentes
même The Voice est en replay tu peux
regarder des états d'épisodes
différemment moi je connais plein de
gens qui consomment comme ça donc c'est
comparé les audiences il y a 4 ans et
comparer les audiences d'aujourd'hui
c'est limite malhonnête
explications
[Rires]
et maintenant
avec Amazon Prime les artistes préfèrent
l'autre viennent de 200000 en un jour
plutôt que 200000 ans
toi qui a vraiment refusé à part Patrick
Bruel pourquoi parce que Patrick Bruel
il a pas besoin de The Voice et qu'il a
surtout pas besoin d'avoir un tampon
marqué de respect
extraordinaire c'est un super chanteur
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez entendu ce que
vient de dire Jean-Michel alors est-ce
que tu as entendu ce que tu viens de
dire Jean-Michel vas-y répète
et là
de citer parmi les tauliers de la
chanson française regarde ce chant bien
sûr il y a Laurent Voulzy aussi
en fait on lui a proposé on lui a
proposé et comme il a dit chez notre ami
Isabelle Morizet sur Europe 1 je vais
lire la première raison c'est que
vraiment j'étais embarqué dans un autre
projet suite à son refus évidemment je
savais que je n'aurais pas le temps de
faire les deux on m'a expliqué que si je
pourrais mais je savais que la lenteur
avec laquelle je travaille c'est ce que
vous avez dit et oui m'empêcherait de me
consacrer à deux choses de cette ampleur
en même temps si honnête de sa part
parce que c'est quand même bien payé et
le chanteur de Rockollection avait avoué
ne pas se sentir à l'aise dans le rôle
de jurer c'est que je me sentais pas
apte à juger des gens c'est un tel amour
Laurent
absolument pas
je me sentais pas apte à juger des gens
dis Laurent Voulzy je ne critique
absolument pas ce qu'ils font je ne dis
pas que je ne le ferai pas un jour mais
quand on me l'a demandé je me sentais
pas de dire qu'il était bien ou pas bien
et je me sentais pas cette étape Laurent
dit Europe 1 2021 regarde Bertrand il y
a eu je crois une émission il y a
longtemps sur NRJ12 avec des animateurs
de télé il y avait une école d'animateur
il y avait des juges donc il y avait des
anciens animateurs qui viennent c'est
super dur comme métier à faire en
réalité quand tu quand tu vois des
animateurs aujourd'hui Cyril on est un
exemple type je pense qu'il y a 20 ans
tu disais ce type va être un animateur
et tu lui aurais donné des conseils
c'est une telle personnalité que tu vois
il y a des gens qui sont devenus
animateurs incroyable sans forcément une
technique d'animateur parce qu'ils ont
une personnalité qui bouleverse tout
quoi
je pourrais pas le faire en tout cas
on dit qu'elle va devenir coach de enfin
directrice de la Star Academy et elle
était déjà directrice de la Star Academy
au Québec et bien par exemple elle est
parfaite pour diriger pour aiguiller
mais je la vois pas en tant que ouais
pas coach en tout cas pas juge parce
qu'elle est pas méchante parce que
justement elle va peut-être pas avoir un
avis qui va être tranchée elle va
vouloir faire de la peine alors que au
contraire pour entourer les élèves c'est
super mais donc du coup ce serait pas
une grande peur
oui parce qu'il y avait que des
difficultés je crois quand même et je
rappelle que Christophe Willem et Julien
Doré avaient été blackboulé de la
nouvelle star comme nous les récupérer
une extrémiste alors la chanteuse du
groupe Texas a été contacté il y avait
même participé au premier réunion tout
de même ça a été loin mais la chanteuse
avait finit par refuser car nous ne se
voyait pas faire de concession je
n'étais pas prête dit-elle à faire des
compromis avec ce que je suis et ce que
sont mes choix quand en réunion je me
suis aperçu qu'il voulait faire un show
télévisé en mettant en avant certaines
personnalités au mépris de la qualité
musicale j'ai dit goodbye vous voyez je
parle anglais parfois c'est
parce que elle c'est justement une
personnalité donc
dans les artistes c'est justement pas
que des voix c'est aussi des
personnalités c'est vraiment scanner
vous savez que la balancé
attends sur TF1 c'est important il faut
quand même que les gens sont très connus
aussi pas sûr que le public le grand
public
mais le grand public
tu la reconnais pas
déjà il savait pas qu'ils étaient
sûrement
une chanson
pic ah oui à l'émission l'auteur
j'aurais plus de dire un candidat oh mon
Dieu qui est fantastique j'aurais aimé
bien chanter comme toi elle chante bien
elle est très belle voix
[Musique]
c'est pas grave vous connaissez les
salaires des jurés
Francesca à peu près je crois par
exemple voilà pour certains non mais
j'ai pas donné des noms mais entre ça
regardez ce n'est pas mal hein 600000
euros pour Zazie pour l'ensemble de la
saison contre 800 000 auparavant ils ont
baissé les tarifs pas de chaussures dans
l'émission
et quel rapport avec les chaussures
je vais vous dire c'est chacun au niveau
du contrat mais si si elle a mal dit les
sons que veux-tu faire on donne 600000 à
Zazie Amel Bent 200000 Bigflo et Oli
alors ils sont deux et c'est 100150 000
pour les deux
carrière
etc
c'est du boulot parce que présente du
boulot alors il y a juste Mika aussi ça
peut choquer un Mika fait une apparition
de 20 mai dernier lors de la phase des
Supercross battle je sais qu'ils a su ça
avec beaucoup d'intérêt il aurait été
payé 100000 € pour la journée de
tournage une journée